Politstar der Linken trouble Shooter
manche nennen in Russland verstehen klar
ist er kann kräftig ausfallen aber auch
ordentlich einstecken Grenzgänger
zwischen Ost und West das alles sagen
die Menschen über unseren heutigen Gast
Gregor Gysi herzlich willkommen ich
grüße sie ebenso Frau sie sind im Osten
aufgewachsen sie haben sich ihr ganzes
Leben lang immer um Verständnis für die
Menschen in Ostdeutschland bemüht und
dann haben wir den ersten Landrat der
AFD in Ostdeutschland auf den ersten
Bürgermeister neueste zahlenweisen für
Thüringen 34% für die AFD aus haben sie
immer noch Verständnis für den Osten
ja klar habe ich Verständnis das Problem
ist nur
wir versuchen uns immer nur damit zu
beschäftigen was die AFD falsch macht
oder auch richtig macht aus der Sicht
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger wir sollten
uns mal damit beschäftigen was wir alles
falsch machen das scheint mir das
entscheidende zu sein von der CDU bis
einschließlich zur Linken das Bild dass
wir abgeben auch meiner Partei mit der
Zerstrittenheit oder diese Form der
Rechthaberei das alles hat Folgen wissen
Sie was mir große Sorgen macht dass bei
der letzten Bundestagswahl in meinen
38,5% der Erwachsenen deutschen
Bevölkerung zum Ausdruck gebracht hat
mit der etablierten Politik von der CSU
bis einschließlich der Linken nichts
mehr anfangen zu können darüber müssen
wir nachdenken im Osten kommt etwas
hinzu dass man keine Vereinigung gemacht
hat sondern wie ich das in meiner einen
Anschluss man hat sich für die DDR nicht
interessiert hätte man sich für die DDR
interessiert hätte man fünf Sachen
übernehmen können weiß ich was wir waren
in einer Gleichstellung der Geschlechter
dabei da es gab eine sehr gute
müllabfassung und Wiederverwendung also
die DDR war so eine behaltegesellschaft
die alte Bundesrepublik war eine
Wegwerfgesellschaft interessanter
Unterschied so das hätte man alles
machen können hat man nicht gemacht und
man hat folgendes verkannt wenn ich es
nicht mache sage ich ja den ostdeutschen
dass sie nichts geleistet haben und
dieses gedrückt Selbstbewusstsein findet
jetzt seinen Ausdruck zum Beispiel auch
in pegida und eben auch bei der Wahl der
AFD und in anderen Umständen und über
diese Fehler denke ich nach und was wir
auch als Linke besser machen können aber
auch die anderen Parteien um einen
falschen Zug aufzuhalten wir machen ja
Wahlforscher als Grund für den Unmut der
letzten Wochen durchaus auch dieses
heizungsgesetz aus da gab es lange
Streit in der Koalition die Abstimmung
über das heizungsgesetz wurde jetzt ähm
verhindert durch Anspruch des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts mit der
Begründung es sei nicht demokratische
hergegangen weil man nicht genug Zeit
gehabt hätte als Abgeordnete sich damit
zu beschäftigen was glauben Sie wie
kommt das im Osten an
das kommt im Osten und am besten habe
ich gleichermaßen schlecht an bisschen
dem Bundeskanzler Scholz würde man
nachgesagt er sei zu zögerlich aber
manchmal ist auch zu hasst dich gar
nicht nur sagen denn wir konnten uns ja
mit dem Gesetz des Vorhaben gar nicht
auseinandersetzen und beschäftigen und
das dann wegen des koalitionsdrucks also
das Freiheit zwischen grün und FDP das
so im Haus ruck-verfahren durchgezogen
werden soll im Bundestag da fühlen sich
viele Abgeordnete und einer ist eben
gleich zum Bundesverfassungsgericht
gegangen was ich gut und richtig finde
wirklich auch überfordert also wenn man
schon die
Bundestagsabgeordneten überfordert wie
überfordert müssen dann andere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sein
ich sage gemacht wir brauchen
ökologische Nachhaltigkeit aber an
sozialer Verantwortung und wenn die
Politik etwas beschließt dann muss sie
auf die Kosten dafür tragen sie kann
nicht sagen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
die kleine und mittelständischen
Unternehmen schaffen das schon irgendwie
und die kriegen kleinen Zuschuss so
läuft das nicht ökologische
Nachhaltigkeit ist nicht billig wie
gehen sie denn nun um oder wir gehen die
anderen Parteien wenn du mit diesem
großen Zuspruch um zu AFD wir haben im
Moment 20% bundesweit geschätzt für die
AFD sagte eben schon 34% in Thüringen wo
die Parteien unter
verfassungsschutzrechtliche Auftritt
steht
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat in seinem
Sommer Interview von der schlechte
launepartei gesprochen ist das einfach
wirklich nur schlechte Laune nein nein
nein nein nein nein gar nicht die
Menschen glauben natürlich dass die AFD
ausgegrenzt wird wenn sie sich selbst
auch ausgegrenzt fühlen ist das schon
ein Grund sie zu wählen aber ist die AFD
gar nicht ausgegrenzt sie kommt in den
Medien vor sie sitzt in allen
Ausschüssen Vorspeise keine
Vizepräsidentin oder ein Vizepräsidenten
und nicht in dem geheimdienstausschuss
vertreten sind sind sie ja nicht
ausgegrenzt an allen anderen Debatten
Reisen etc nehmen sie ja Teil aber
abgesehen davon
spricht das schon wieder für Sie und das
nutzt sie ja natürlich auch entsprechend
nur wissen sie
mit schlechter Laune alleine hat das
nicht zu tun man muss sich tiefer
gehende Gedanken machen weshalb der
Nationalismus eine immer größere Rolle
spielt auch wenn ich an die Türkei denke
wenn ich an Frankreich denke wenn ich an
Polen denke
wenn ich ein unge denke und wenn ich bei
uns an die AFD etc denke das ist der
eine Grund warum ich glaube dass die
Menschen Angst haben vor der
Globalisierung und die rechten Parteien
tun immer so als ob sie alles national
gelöst bekämmen das ist bei der
ökologischen Nachhaltigkeit schon absurd
aber auch in der sozialen Frage absurd
wissen Sie was wirklich neu ist
die soziale Frage war überwiegend eine
nationale Frage aber nun ist ja das
Internet erfunden worden und das Handy
das heißt alle Menschen weltweit können
ein Lebensstandard Vergleich sich selbst
organisieren das heißt der Ingenieur und
Uganda weiß ganz genau wie als Ingenieur
in Deutschland oder in China oder in den
USA oder sonst wo lebte und darauf fällt
den Regierungen nichts ein gar nichts
und das ist zu wenig und deshalb haben
wir überall eine Entwicklung hin zu
solchen Strukturen wenn ich ein Erdogan
und viele andere denke wissen Sie was
mir drei Leute mal gesagt haben warum
Sie Erdogan gewählt haben weil der etwas
ankündigt und sechs Wochen später ist es
Realität und da hat er gesagt und ihr
Quatsch zwei Jahre und es ist immer noch
nicht Realität stimmt ja dann habe ich
gesagt und das Wasser sagt willst wollt
ihr auch haben sie gesagt ja ich weiß
was macht ihr wenn er vier Dinge
ankündigt hier nicht wollt
die sind ja auch sechs Wochen später
Realität das heißt man muss erklären
dass der Wahl der dem Vorzug der
Demokratie zum Beispiel auch daran
besteht dass man nicht nur jemanden
wählen kann sondern indirekt auch jemand
abwählen kann und die Möglichkeiten
werden immer geringer hier autoritärer
die Strukturen sind aber wenn wir jetzt
bei diesem Vergleich bleiben in den
Schulen schon die Bild die wirklich die
Ausbildung zur Demokratie und zur
Freiheit ja aber bleiben wir mal bei dem
Vergleich und sie sagen die Freiheit des
Internets an Ingenieur in Uganda kann
aber ein Ingenieur zum Beispiel in
Ostdeutschland oder meinetwegen auch in
Westdeutschland kann natürlich auch
sehen dass es ihm unendlich viel besser
geht das funktioniert ja auch andersrum
warum haben wir dann so viel
zugesprochen bei einer vermeintlichen
Protestpartei ja weil die Leute machen
ja keinen Vergleich nach unten man
überlegt sich ja nicht wie man lebte
wenn man im Bangladesch lebte sondern
man lebt hier in Deutschland hier hat
man ja auch seine Erlebnisse und hier
gibt es ja auch Armut und nicht wenig
und dagegen wird viel zu wenig getan und
dann muss die Linke sich sehr viel
stärker engagieren ich sage ökologische
Nachhaltigkeit immer nur mit sozialem
Ausgleich der wird aber nicht immer
gesucht und auch nicht immer gefunden
das geht alles nicht und dann kommen
eben eine falsche Sprache in der Politik
hinzu ich meine die können stundenlang
im Bundestag über die Veräußerungserlös
Gewinnsteuer reden und kein Mensch
übersetzt was das ist also außer mir
natürlich ich übersetze das tatsächlich
das ist ein Gewinn aus einem Kaufpreis
das heißt du verkaufst etwas unternehmen
machten Gewinn und ich will jetzt gar
nicht weiter darauf eingehen und wie das
alles geregelt ist meine saßen völlig
falsch geregelt das ist wieder eine
andere Frage sondern der Punkt ist sehr
keine verständliche Sprache dann werden
oft nicht die wirklichen Beweggründe
einer politischen Entscheidung
wiedergegeben
und SPD irgendeine politische
Entscheidung treffen
dann lautet der zweite
Tagesordnungspunkt wie verkaufen wir es
an die Bevölkerung weil sie sich dann
überlegen wir müssen eine Begründung
finden die die Mehrheit in erster Linie
akzeptiert die Mehrheit merkt aber dass
sie Begründung oft nicht immer aber oft
gar nicht stimmt und das erhöht das
Misstrauen für zu den 38,5 % und eine
Soziologin hat mir erklärt die Zahl
nimmt nicht ab sondern täglich zu und
wissen Sie
meine Kollegen und Kollegen im Bundestag
machen sich viel zu wenig Gedanken
darüber es gibt auch keine
parteiübergreifende Gruppe weiß ich
cdu/csu sPD Grüne FDP wir wo wir uns mal
Gedanken machen weshalb so viel
Vertrauen in der Bevölkerung verspielt
wurde und was man anders machen muss um
das Vertrauen wieder herzustellen aber
das Vertrauen muss man sagen hat ja
gerade auch die Linke vor allen Dingen
in Ostdeutschland verspielt sie galten
ja damals als die Kamera Partei sie
hatten den Zuspruch es hieß damals immer
auch nach der Wende ist hieß immer ja
wenn hier einer vor Ort ist dann sind es
die Linken und die Leute hatten ja
Vertrauen warum haben sie das verspielt
und ja nachdem sich die PDS zu Recht
entschlossen hat sich mit der BSG zu
vereinigen zur Partei DIE LINKE hat man
in erster Linie den Schwerpunkt daran
gesehen sich im Westen aufzubauen ich
habe immer gesagt wir dürfen den Osten
nicht vernachlässigen der spielte dann
aber auch in der Fraktion nicht mehr die
gleiche Rolle wie vorher ich weiß noch
17 habe ich abstimm ung zu retten sowas
haben wir alles organisiert früher das
ging natürlich auch im Osten rum das
haben aber jetzt die meisten erkannt und
wir bemühen uns diese Fehler wieder zu
korrigieren wird auch höchste Zeit was
nehmen Sie sich denn persönlich da übel
ich nehme mir übel in der Fraktion nicht
mehr darauf gedrungen zu haben sondern
weil ich mir gesagt habe du warst mal
Fraktionsvorsitzender das ist jetzt ganz
blöde wenn du dann immer als
oberschlauer leermeister der herkommst
und sah so und so und habe mich dann
eher zurückgehalten war vielleicht
falsch und waren wir am Anfang ja schon
dabei wir haben jetzt ein Landrat der
AFD wir haben einen Bürgermeister und
die etabliert Politik schließt geht jede
Form von Zusammenarbeit aus wir hören
aber zunehmend auch Landräte die sagen
wir müssen miteinander arbeiten wir
müssen miteinander sprechen wie soll das
gehen wie sollen wir über den
Müllabfuhrgebühren wir sollen wir das
alles besprechen wenn wir jetzt
Vertreter der AFD ausgrenzen haben sie
da Verständnis für das geht gar nicht
anders auf der kommunal Ebene brauchst
du ja egal ob es eine Gemeindevertretung
ist sondern eine
Stadtverordnetenversammlung brauchst ja
nicht Zusammenarbeit im bestimmten
politischen Fragen und vor allen Dingen
wenn das dein Landrat ist oder es ist
dein Bürgermeister der musste sowieso
mit ihm reden anders geht es ja gar
nicht das ändert aber nichts daran dass
man versuchen muss
Bürgerinnen und Bürger davon zu
überzeugen dass es bessere Wege gibt als
diese das muss man immer wieder machen
und Daten muss man auch dran bleiben
oder muss man auch konsequent sein
trotzdem ich sage noch einmal wir müssen
uns damit beschäftigen warum die anderen
Parteien so viel Vertrauen verloren
haben und wenn man sich damit
beschäftigt und das besser macht dann
kann man es auch erreichen allein diese
ausschließliche die führt zu nichts
sondern nur dass ich mir edel vorkomme
sage ich mache es ja nicht Punkt aber
das Glück nicht wir müssen über
Strukturen Nachdenken über Ehrlichkeit
Nachdenken über verständliche Sprache
nachdenken wir müssen auch Politik
nachvollziehbar machen auch in
komplizierten Strukturen wir müssen auch
Zeiträume erklären die Vergehen und wir
müssen aus Fehlern lernen ich sag immer
ein Beispiel der Bundesrechnungshof
deshalb fantastisch die ist ja stellt
der Welt welches Geld sinnlos von den
Bundesministerien ausgegeben worden ist
und das ist nicht mal so einfach dazu
eine Debatte im Bundestag hinzukriegen
und hinzubekommen wie man das abstellen
kann etc und da fühlen sich die Leute
natürlich betrogen bei ihnen fehlt der
kleine Betrachtung dafür kein Weg rein
und da geht es immer so um Millionen die
irgendwie geschaukelt werden und falsch
geschaukelt werden leute Leute sage ich
immer bin man muss sich das immer
überlegen aus der Sicht einer Hartz IV
Empfängerin einer Minijobberin einer mit
Mindestrente oder eben auch normale
Arbeitnehmerin und Arbeitnehmer die
anderen sind ja nicht unnormal also
durchschnittlich verdiente
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer die
müssen überall genau rechnen dass ich
alles genau überlegen und da kannst du
nicht immer so jonglieren wie das in der
Bundespolitik zum Teil geschieht mit
Aussicht haben
nämlich wenn wir auf Ihre eigene Partei
schauen wo ist ja nur ein Moment auch
wieder mal sage ich ziemlich turbulent
zugeht
es geht um die Abspaltung um die
erwartete Abspaltung Sarah wagen
ganz klar wenn sie es machen ich hoffe
ja sie machen es nicht ich bemühe mich
ja auch das zu verhindern aber wissen
Sie ich muss ihm folgendes sagen 1990
und in der Zeit danach hat man versucht
meine Partei auszuschalten und zwar über
den politischen moralischen Weg das
haben aber unsere Gegner und unsere
Konkurrenten nicht geschafft dann kam
von unseren Gegnern und Konkurrenten der
Versuch uns finanziell auszuschalten
über Steuerbescheide es sind auch nicht
gelungen und nun haben sich ein paar
linke gedacht ja wenn Sie den Gegnern
und Konkurrent nicht gelingt müssen wir
es eben selbst versuchen versteht sich
und diese Aufgabe wahrnehmen anstatt im
Innern zu ringen um Mehrheiten zu
kämpfen zu streiten das ist ja alles
legitim finde ich diesen Weg zu gehen
und was neues aufzumachen falsch aber
wenn dann entsteht in mir wieder
Leidenschaft ich war führend daran
beteiligt die ersten beiden
auflösungsversuche
zu verhindern ich werde auch bei dem
dritten
energisch dagegen auftreten ich hoffe
dass es nicht passiert aber wenn es
passiert dann müssen wir wie man so
schön sagt in Berlin Kante zeigen also
dann muss gekämpft werden man glaubt man
ja dass Sarah Wagenknecht im Falle einer
Neugründung einer Partei durchaus bei
der AFD Wähler abziehen könnte weil sie
offenbar ja was die Migrationspolitik
angeht ähm relativ auf einen oder
zumindest auf einem ähnlichen Level
argumentiert während die Sozialpolitik
ja doch absolut Verein wahrscheinlich
mit dem was ich sage jetzt mal die
restlinke im Moment möchte wenn sie
sagen man muss darüber streiten wo sind
da wo sind da die Grenzen wo sagen sie
da muss Schluss sein oder wo sagen sie
da fehlt uns jegliches Verständnis das
können wir nicht mitgehen dann müssen
wir uns wirklich trennen
das ist bei uns sehr weit gefasst wenn
du natürlich wirklich ganz rechter
Auffassung hast das geht natürlich nicht
werden Grenzen gezogen meine Partei muss
was Flüchtlinge betrifft in erster Linie
für eine vernünftige Integration
streiten die es nie gegeben hat das
sehen wir jetzt übrigens auch in
Frankreich wenn du die Ghetto isierst
und so weiter welche Folgen das ganze
hat auch noch in der zweiten und in der
dritten Generation das ist unsere
Aufgabe nicht die Zahl darüber sollen
sich doch die anderen streiten natürlich
Gründe Menschen müssen in Not sein damit
sie ja Asyl haben immer ein Beispiel
alle Parteien im Bundestag alle sagen
der Krieg Russland gegen die Ukraine
Völkerrechts für dich aber die AFD und
die CDU CSU sagen junge Männer aus
Russland die Fliegen in Nachbarländer
nehmen wir nicht auf sie bekommen keinen
humanitäres Visum
Unverschämtheit also man sagt der Krieg
ist Völkerrecht Friedrich und dann sage
ich den jungen Männern ihr sollt aber
daran teilnehmen entweder Ukraine
erschießen oder selber erschossen werden
oder ins Gefängnis gehen wegen wenn sie
es Verweigerung also wenn man das so
einschätzen muss man ja auch zu einer
humanitären Geste bereits sein finde ich
aber abgesehen davon
dieser Wunsch
die Wählerinnen und Wähler der AFD zu
gewinnen ist meistens schief gegangen
das hat die CSU versucht in Bayern ist
es nicht gelungen dann legitimierst du
nämlich die Wahl der AFD und das zweite
ist dass nach einer Untersuchung ein
Prozent der Wählerinnen und Wähler der
AFD nachdenken dass sie auch uns fehlen
könnten aber bei den Grünen bei der SPD
sind es immer zwischen 15 und 20%, also
wo die Aufgaben liegen kann man da ja
leicht entdecken und ich sage Ihnen noch
was halbrechts halb links zu sein das
funktioniert nicht man muss sich
entscheiden und das wiederum die Rechten
immer auch soziale Forderungen stellen
das ist nicht neu das haben sie immer
gemacht in der Geschichte weil sie ja
immer versuchen darzustellen dass sie
das Volk in der ganzen Breite vertreten
nun würde aber sozusagen ein Abgang
seiner Wagenknecht mit einer neuparte
Gründung einer Partei auf jeden Fall
bedeuten dass sie noch mehr fürchten
müssen um die Sitze in bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl auch bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl hattest du die Linke ja
nur mit Ach und Krach geklappt und vor
allen Dingen weil sie drei Direktmandate
hatten über die 5% wären sie nicht
gekommen nun haben wir ein neues
Wahlrecht dass die Ampel vorgeschlagen
hat gegen das sie auch zu Felde ziehen
in Karlsruhe
wie sehr tendieren sie dazu im
Zweifelsfall auch alleine als Parteilose
anzutreten wenn dieses Wahlrecht kennen
weil ihr direkt Mandat im Köpenick
hätten sie würde ich jetzt mal behaupten
doch trotzdem so gut wie sicher naja das
ist ja ein rechtliches Problem aber ich
will ihn nur sagen wenn das passiert sie
haben völlig recht das würde uns
natürlich Schwächen aber dann entsteht
auch Kampfgeist vieler bei den
Mitgliedern dann entsteht auch wieder
Leidenschaft ich kenne das wenn du so
scheinbar gedrückt wirst dass du jetzt
erst recht aber sie haben recht das
Wahlrecht ist meines Erachtens
Grundgesetz für sich ich nenn ihn
versuche es ganz kurz zu machen also
wenn ich direkt antrete in meinem
Wahlkreis Treptow Köpenick und nicht von
der Partei aufgestellt werden und die
Partei darum verzichtet jemanden
aufzustellen dann bin ich wenn ich die
relative Mehrheit Gewinne auf jeden Fall
Mitglied des Bundestages wenn mich die
Partei als Direktkandidat aufstellt und
ich bekomme dieselben stimmen
und die Partei schafft nicht die fünf
Prozent oder würde ich nicht Mitglied
des Bundestag das ist völlig undenkbar
nicht die Wählerinnen und Wähler
entscheiden über das Mandat sondern die
Art der Aufstellung verstehen sie das
hat mit dem Grundgesetz nicht zu tun das
zweite was sie nicht begriffen haben ist
die Regelung dass man bei drei
Direktmandaten einzieht oder wenn man 5%
der Zweitstimmen schafft sind ja
kommunizierende Röhren wenn du also
sagst du schaffst die drei Direktmandat
Regelung ab dann musst du die 5%
vielleicht auf 3 % senken wenn du es
erhöhst und sagst nicht drei
Direktmandate genügen soll man braucht
wenigstens fünf dann müsstest du auf
vier Prozent runter gehen das sind
kommunizierende Röhren was vergessen
worden ist und dann kommt noch was hinzu
was auch unterschätzt wird mal
angenommen ich werde wieder aufgestellt
von der Partei als Direktkandidat und
die Partei liegt immer so bei 4% in den
Umfragen dann werden ja die Leute
demotiviert mich zu wählen weil sie
sagen der zieht ja sowieso nicht ein
wenn ich allerdings alleine antrete ohne
die Partei und dann ziehe ich immer ein
wenn ich sie relative Mehrheit habe dann
motiviert man sie mich zu werden also
alles ein bisschen idiotisch muss ich
sagen und deshalb bin ich davon
überzeugt dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das Korrigieren
wird aber damit ich nicht missverstanden
bin ich bin für eine deutliche
Verkleinerung des Bundestages wir sind
das zweitgrößte Parlament der Welt wir
sind aber nicht das zweitgrößte Land der
Welt wenn ich mal sagen größer ist nur
noch das Parlament in Peking also ich
finde die Rolle als zweitgrößtes
Parlament sollten wir abgeben aber da
gibt es andere Wege erzähle ich Ihnen
gerne aber ich glaube nicht dass wir
noch die Zeit dafür haben okay aber
abschließend zu dem Thema erlauben wir
uns doch vielleicht doch das
Gedankenspiel tritt Gregor Gysi in jedem
Fall wieder an zur nächsten Bundestag
Wahl ob mit linke oder als verteillose
das weiß ich doch heute noch nicht dazu
kann ich jetzt noch kein anderer Fällen
jetzt will ich erstmal die Linke die
Fraktion und auch Bürgerinnen und Bürger
vertreten vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht und da reichen
dass das was da beschlossen wurde
korrigiert ist und dabei jetzt ja schon
ein gewissen Erfolg hat dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat
abgeordnete müssen doch über ein Gesetz
nachdenken können ne was eben die
Regierung für überflüssig hielt dass wir
darüber nachdenken könnten wir
vielleicht auch beim Wahlrecht erfolgen
auf die Außenpolitik ihr momentanesamt
ist ja außenpolitischer Sprecher sie
haben sich unmittelbar nach dem
Angriffskrieg Wladimir Putins
distanziert von Putin und auch von
Russland haben aber immer gesagt dass
sie gegen Waffenlieferung aus
Deutschland sind gilt das immer noch ja
das hat aber eine speziellen Grund in
unserer Geschichte Deutschland trägt die
Verantwortung für den schlimm gewissen
Krieg der Menschheitsgeschichte den
Zweiten Weltkrieg mit 50 Millionen Toten
habe ich noch nicht beim Holocaust nur
Kriegstoten 50 Millionen und deshalb
finde ich dass wir nicht mehr an Kriegen
verdienen dürfen wir sind aber der fünf
größte Waffenexporteur der Welt der
fünftgrößte wir verdienen an jedem Krieg
egal ob der Libyen stattfindet in Syrien
stattfindet im Irak oder wo und deshalb
sage ich ich bin strikt dagegen dass
Deutschland überhaupt Waffen exportiert
man kann das auch anders sehen aber das
ist meine Sicht aufgrund meiner
Entwicklung meiner Familie aber das ist
betrifft ja nicht Frankreich nicht
Großbritannien nicht USA die können ja
Waffen liefern zur Stärkung oder
selbstverteidigungsrechts nur haben wir
eine neue Situation die general Militär
das ist immerhin der Generalstab
beschäftigt der US-Streitkräfte sagt
wieder Russland noch die Ukraine kann
den Krieg gewinnen und so sieht es ja
auch aus es
es wird jeden Tag zerstört es gibt
verletzt es gibt Tote aber keiner kommt
wirklich ein Stück voran ja wenn das so
ist dann bin ich für ein sofortigen
Waffenstillstand und damit auch gegen
Waffenlieferung dann wird mir wieder
gesagt putin wilkay war eine Stillstand
sage ich mal gut dann kann man noch
folgendes machen die NATO nach
Rücksprache mit der ukrainischen
Regierung sagt also wir bieten euch an
ab 0 Uhr übermorgen keine einzige Waffe
mehr in die Ukraine zu liefern wenn ihr
mit einem Waffenstillstand einverstanden
seid das würde Putin in Schwierigkeiten
bringen der Männer nein sagt sagte er
setzt mal eure Waffenlieferung fort also
ich glaube dass er darauf einginge und
dann muss hart verhandelt werden ich bin
dagegen dass die Ukraine Tiere Träume
aufgibt aber es muss dann hart
verhandelt werden damit wir endlich zu
einem Frieden kommen da brauchst du eine
Vermittlung Dritter ich glaube schon
scheiden inzwischen aus Erdogan halte
ich auch nicht für so wahnsinnig
geeignet aber vielleicht Präsident Luder
aus Brasilien und auch ab afrikanische
Staaten Regierung von A amerikanischen
Staaten könnten damit wirken ich möchte
dass das Töten das verletzen und das
Zerstören aufhören und zwar so schnell
wie möglich und dann brauchen wir eine
neue Friedensordnung in Europa jetzt
denken alle es geht nur noch mit
Aufrüstung mein Gott was wir für
Milliarden da reinstecken und ich glaube
genau umgekehrt wir müssen
deeskalieren wir brauchen
Interessenausgleich wir brauchen viel
mehr Diplomatie und wir brauchen die
strikte Wahrung des Völkerrechts
russland hat das Völkerrecht verletzt
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen die
ersten die nach dem Kalten Krieg das
Völkerrecht verletzt haben war die NATO
mit dem Krieg gegen Serbien die Trennung
des Kosovo verstößt gegen einen noch
heute gültigen Beschluss des
Sicherheitsrates der UNO der Krieg der
USA gegen den Rad war auch
völkerrechtswiderlich ich will das nicht
gleichsetzen der Krieg ist jetzt viel
schlimmer aber ich will nur sagen wir
der Westen hat zuerst das Völkerrecht
verletzt
weil wir dachten wir können es uns
leisten und jetzt stellen wir fest wir
können es uns nicht leisten denn wenn
wir das Völkerrecht nicht einhalten dann
eben auch Russland nicht und andere
nicht also müssen alle Staaten zum
Völkerrecht zurückkehren sonst kriegen
wir eine Friedensordnung nicht
geschaffen damit uns im Moment der Blick
wohl zurück eher wenig weil das ändert
ja nichts an der Situation im Moment zu
sagen jeder jeder würde unterschreiben
dass das Töten und dieser Krieg
schnellstmöglich beendet werden soll
alleine kein Mensch kann sich im Moment
vorstellen dass das ein absehbarer Zeit
der Fall wäre dann haben wir nächste
Woche den NATO Gipfel den Sondergipfel
in willius und da wird es vor allen
Dingen darum gehen ob die Ukraine in die
NATO gehört die Ukraine den NATO das ist
eine Frage die aktuell ja gar nicht
ansteht wir können ja gar kein Land in
die Natur aufnehmen das gerade sich im
Krieg befindet das schließt schon das
Statut der Natur Vorschläge nur die
Teile die sich im Moment noch nicht im
Kriegsgeschehen befinden zum Beispiel
schon mal aufzulernen das kann man alles
nicht machen das glaube ich ist der
falsche Weg immer im Rahmen von
Friedensverhandlungen muss allerdings
herauskommen dass auch der Westen die
Sicherheit der Ukraine garantieren muss
in welcher Form auch immer das ist
wichtig das können wir nicht offen
lassen nach diesem Angriffskrieg das ist
mir klar aber da müssen natürlich auch
noch bestimmte Dinge in der Ukraine sich
verändern darf man ja auch nicht
vergessen dass das kein so ganz
einfaches Land war etc die Einstellung
von Putin muss sich ändern dass er noch
so zuständig ist für fast alle
ehemaligen sonderrepubliken das geht
nicht oder nicht nur von Putin sondern
überhaupt der russischen Führung das
muss ich auch ändern also vieles muss
ich ändern es bringt nur immer nichts
wenn ich denke die anderen müssen sich
ändern ich selbst muss aber nichts
korrigieren ich erreiche immer dann was
wenn ich sage ich weiß ich muss das
korrigieren aber du musst auch das und
das und das Korrigieren sehen Sie unter
dem Augenblick finde ich es falsch wenn
die NATO sagt wir stellen uns auf weiß
ich nicht was 2 Jahre alt 5 Jahre alt 10
Jahre alt Krieg wie viel tote Ukrainerin
und Ukraine bedeutet das tote Russin und
Russen bedeutet das deshalb wäre ich
dafür woran aber die NATO noch kein
Interesse hat so schnell wie möglich auf
einen Waffenstillstand zu drängen und
dann müssen die komplizierten
Friedensverhandlungen beginnen ohne dass
die Ukraine Territorium verliert der
berühmte und bekannte Philosoph Habermas
hat gesagt es gibt einen Unterschied ob
man sagt die Ukraine muss siegen oder ob
man sagt die Ukraine darf nicht
verlieren sie darf auf jeden Fall nicht
verlieren aber was hat allerdings auch
mal von sich gesagt der einzige der
Jürgen habermaß versteht ist Jürgen
habermaß so gesehen das finde ich wieder
eine schöne Selbstironie sowas gefällt
mir eher
das Parlament geht jetzt in die
Sommerferien am Ende der Sommerferien
beginnt der Wahlkampf für die
Landtagswahlen in Bayern oder den Hessen
sieht es nicht alles gut aus für die
Linke mal vorsichtig ausgedrückt mit
welchen Gefühlen gehen sie denn in die
Sommerferien
mein Urlaub dauert noch eine Weile ich
habe noch reichlich zu tun im ganzen
Monat Juli ich freue mich auf die
Sommerferien bei einer Weile geht einem
als Bundestagsabgeordnete auf der
Bundestag auf dem dort und man braucht
eine Pause bis man da wieder hingeht
wobei ich dann wieder sage Menschen
andere Arbeit brauchen ja auch eine
Pause haben sie aber nicht so viel wie
Bundestagsabgeordnete ja und dann hoffe
ich dass wir noch erleben
so schnell wie möglich ein Ende dieses
Krieges dass wir erleben
das parteiübergreifend nachgedacht wird
woher der Vertrauensverlust in der
Bevölkerung kommt und was man dagegen
tun kann dass wir endlich begreifen wenn
wir politisch eine Einschränkung
beschließen oder die Leute zwingen etwas
anders zu machen beim Heizen oder wo
auch immer dass wir dann auch die
Verantwortung für die Kosten tragen und
nicht die Leute nicht die kleinen und
auch nicht die mittelständischen
Unternehmen
Gregor Gysi vielen Dank für das Gespräch
[Musik]